we were talking mik cut cord cord cutout
we're talking about the LA Giants
obviously they're all over the project
yeah um they just fit they just fit we
the same type of what's crazy is because
all of these artists I've worked with um
I can't say everybody had as much of a
la experience as I have right everybody
hasn't been a gang banger if they have
they haven't low they haven't had a low
rider been on crin y um if they have you
know maybe they never sold do or if they
have maybe they never Street raced you
know maybe they never functioned the LA
Johns was like the first acts that I
worked with to me that did all of the
same La things that I
did including risk your life for some
good chicken yes yeah yeah it's [__]
true which is a which is song number
seven yeah Jim Dandy but it's like that
in so many different places it's funny
because that's like a TV show I'm
finishing up I wrode and I'm F to shoot
uh van a couple homies helping me to
produce it but um dying at your own risk
that's the experience in La yeah there
are always people who are like yo man
there's some great because what's the
the OG Louisiana chicken is where in a
tray and it's like if if you're over
there it's dangerous it's dangerous but
that's how it is uh so Jim dandies and
Denver Lange Bloods right then you have
Hawkins and across street from the
Nickerson Gardens the boners um Louis
the best chili cheese fries in Compton
is right in the mob Hood you just kind
of got to figure out how to get to all
of these places and get away with it and
when you go you got to like really just
not have on your your stuff right like
you would I'm I'm past that people knew
who I I mean people know who you are
yeah but I'm saying it's been a long
time they can smell a [__] like people
could smell gang banging other gang
bangers can smell other gang bangers
that's why if they like hit you up they
oh where you from like oh man uh where
you who is your mama where you live
where you grew up at like you know
they'll smell out they could tell yeah I
mean I've always uh head always tells me
and I don't know if this is good advice
or bad advice but he said if I ever end
up somewhere and I have a couple of
times where I was getting gas somewhere
and I called AE this happened like he
posted it on Instagram cuz I hit him and
I was like yo I'm right here am I good
to get something to eat I'm getting gas
and he's like what the [__] are you
doing there yeah but he head would
always say he's like yo if you end up
somewhere and you get banged on just
start acting like real fr like you're in
the middle of a crazy fight with your
girl and you got lost like man my bad
bro sorry [__] fighting with my [__]
bro I don't know where the [__] cuz
that's a universal masculine thing right
we all be like oh man I just got caught
cheating thisit tripping bro he like man
she [__] had me get out the car my
bad bro do your thing yeah yeah man my
bad you know that's what head say it's
true it works it works he like just just
act like you're in the middle of a crazy
fight with your girl you don't know
where you're at and you know get on your
phone and like it should be all right
yeah yeah yeah now for the most part
it's okay I mean gang
bangers the most underrated part about
gang banging is they're pretty
understanding yeah if they sober if
they're
sober like most humans that's like hey I
about say that's a pretty general
statement for the world but gang banging
they get worse when you know you drunk
because you get superpowered and people
be charged up yeah like my wife when she
gets mad if she's drunk and mad it's
over it's over another Lev Latina oh
yeah yeah that's Spanish cuss words
Spanish cuss words yeah there's a lot of
Spanish cuss words I've been called um
okay so if someone gets your C
physically and they look at the back you
have obviously you got West Coast cam
you got sugarfree shout out to sugar
free the legend I need you to help me
get connected with him sure I got you I
got you um but then you also have Samuel
Jackson and the Notorious BIG listed as
features yeah yeah yeah um explain both
I just feel like it's always weird when
you looking at a track list and then
somebody voice pop up who the [__] is
that and I just put that there like um
obviously on Spotify I didn't try to
infringe on their audiences but I wanted
people to know that that voice you hear
is gonna be biggie this voice is going
to be Jackson marle Luther King or
Samuel Jackson or that's fair Cedric the
Entertainer you also have um the guy who
plays Jesus um in the music video for
slink slink Johnson yeah shout out to
slink Johnson he did a really good job
on uh Freddy Gibbs album too he kind of
was like a he did one of the skits on
his album uh and he did great on your
music video yeah yeah uh what's it say
forch [__] for the [__] for [__]
which is um an Ode
to uh it's weird because right there's a
men with bedazzled anklets that and just
just straight men impeding on women's
beauty standards in the first place
completely top to bottom I tell them all
the time straight man Cyrus my shooter
over there got two earrings in that you
know what's funny that 30 40 years ago
that would have been L frown at 20 years
ago that's normal mhm when when I was
growing up my dad used to always tell me
if you have an earring on a certain side
of meant that you were gay yeah oh yeah
like the right side right and if you
have both it's like what girls do yeah
that's true and that that used to be
that way that used to be that way then R
Kelly kicked that down cuz he had them
things him in AI you know what I'm
saying but no this album in general cuz
you're listen man if y'all don't follow
glasses on Twitter he's one of the most
frustrating entertaining follows ever
there are very few things that I I so me
and you it's funny because I'm getting
ready to redo the whole set and a lot of
my set is going to be dedicated I bought
a doggy style on vinyl the OG vinyl good
that's good and I bought the uh o OG
cassette i' have had three copies of the
SE I was a kid that's a good one but you
and I are very aligned with some hip-hop
opinions some very very some and four
out of 10 most of most of the ones that
we're very passionately dug in on have
to do with Snoop and have to do with
doggy style because doggy style is the
most important hip-hop album in my
entire life sure and it's the most it's
the greatest one of all hipop and I I
kind of have like a three album where I
could be like this this is my goat album
right it's IL Matic it's Doggy Styles
probably get rich your die trying it in
any order that those could be one two or
three on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday whatever but doggy s was the
most important in my life that's fair
and in my opinion Snoop Dog somehow
while being the most famous rapper in
the world by far still underrated he's
underrated yes agree how is this a
possibility by the way my bucket list
interview I hit his guy Kev once a month
and I'm like dude I'll go to the it's my
bucket list alltime interview if I can
interview Snoop I might cry CU I want to
explain to him me getting doggy style on
accident changed the path of my life but
how is Snoop still
underrated how does that happen well
he's the greatest hip-hop artist of all
time right but if you favor certain
Styles maybe Snoop won't fit that style
so immediately he's from the West so
that's going to immediately take credit
from the the Cornerstone of hip-hop in
New York or the East Coast that's going
to be a Cornerstone issue that he's not
from the right East he's from the West
um his style is like a
oneoff you know I mean to me it's like a
descendant of like short and LL cooj
super smooth you know what I mean but
you can see he's such a hip-hop kid like
First videos you can see the special ed
in his movements how he moved and how
smooth he was um I think the majority of
it is one he's from the west coast and
not from the East two would probably
be he's
alive he's alive that's real real [__]
you know what I mean he's alive and
that's really important which is even
greater because you look at him now and
he's probably like
still the most recognizable mhm you know
rapper on the planet no I I do say that
I say there's certain artists that if
God forbid they passed away would shoot
to the greatest of all and I I really
think think that about Kendrick like I
tell people like oh yeah we we really
kind of don't appreciate Kendrick like
we should CU if he passed away tomorrow
for whatever reason he's the goat um
he's at least he's at least like
solidified in that conversation in the
same way we talk about P it's really
dope and I try not to comment on dot
because you know dot is my friend and
somebody I I love
you guys have done records together way
way deeper you know mean this [__]
really my partner but it's like he's
also a generation undermines so I have
to listen to a lot of younger people
tell me versus me giving my cuz I I have
[__] that I'm looking like you know
Scarface say scarf it's like as much as
I love do it's like Scarface you know me
he raised me do is like well I would
just say cuz like we put biggie in
certain conversations based on two
albums when he was alive we got two
albums from them them albums is some
[__] that well no those albums are
incredible but what I'm saying is if you
if if you look at just like if something
happened to died it it'd be frantic it'd
be frantic it it it would probably re it
would probably reshape hip-hop at that
point permanently I think unfortunately
people sometimes when they
leave uh prematurely they get
appreciated more and I think we've
seeing that happen a lot time and time
again over the last decade or or or or
their Spirit can be free the r about the
cabin yeah cuz I think a lot of times we
don't get into like even with nip right
I always felt like people look at gang
bangers and feel like I can't relate
right even though like you know [__]
is regular human beings but they can't
relate and I think it became so
important for people to to get what he
was on when he passed away cuz it made
him mortal right people really look at
gang banging like like a he-man sport
like oh man if they die I don't care or
you know or they can't die or they did
something to die or they in prison you
know versus some dude just really
running a business and having a problem
and somebody taking his life and I think
there's nothing more human than that so
I think that's what happened with him